alright hey friends I'm amazed we got
this many developers to wake up at nine
o'clock on a on a Wednesday it's
fantastic to be here thank you so much
for having me it's so much nicer of a
venue than it was at the original NDC a
lot more people came but I still enjoyed
speaking to that guy as Jacob said my
name is Scott Hanselman I hope you check
out my podcast I've got a show called
Hansel minutes it's 30 minutes long and
I'm up to 550 episodes I've been doing
that for 10 years every Thursday giving
you a 30 minute technology agnostic
podcast that does not waste your time so
definitely please check that out and
then of course if you've been to MDC or
you from familiar with in DC you're
familiar with Rob Connery he and I do
this developers life still got a great
back catalogue and we're working on new
episodes so check out this developers
life as well and then most recently we
did marches for makers which was a IOT
and maker focused s-- site filled with
podcasts and Google Hangouts and
articles and all sorts of great stuff
that just makes us very very happy about
technology now I do oh how to apologize
ahead of time of course we know that I
work at Microsoft but I work remotely
for on the forests on the forest moon
safely outside the Redmond reality
distortion field which allows me to work
on open source which is really great and
of course when I went to work at
Microsoft people said that I was a
sellout and that I was going there for
the money and I have to say that it hurt
my feelings it hurt my feelings a lot
and I didn't know really how I was going
to deal with that but somehow I dug deep
and I found it in myself to deal with
those feelings because we all know what
I looked like before Microsoft that was
me and here's me after Microsoft
so even though it is as a as a pretty
complicated org chart working at
Microsoft is a is a constant joy now I
was talking with an older gentleman at
at Intel a couple of years ago and I I
think he was somewhere between 80 and
120 and he was like one of the original
Intel employees and he had come to a
talk that I was doing on web development
and he said he wanted to learn how to be
a web programmer this felt really weird
because well I've got 25 years
experience he's got 50 so he's let means
he's literally forgotten more than I
would that I know right now and he said
I want to be a web developer and I
thought to myself I don't know how you
how you missed out in the last 20 years
but it turns out he was doing low-level
microcode you know internal BIOS type
stuff and he literally skipped the whole
internet part of the last 20 years so I
got to thinking what would it look like
if we explained how to write
applications for the Internet to someone
who was a smart computer science person
but missed the last 20 years he was like
Rip Van Winkle except with code this is
him taking a selfie just to give you a
sense of the level of individual that
we're talking about right here
the kind of person who can like look at
some Lisp and like immediately know
what's going on and say oh you missed
the you missed a close parenthesis there
and then they know exactly how many
close parentheses to add and then it's
suddenly that app compiles you know
we're talking about Grace Hopper type
people where you know what were you
doing you weren't on the internet no I
was sorry I was busy inventing the
compiler so I wanted to explain to him
what I thought was going on in the
Internet and that this was a great time
to become a web developer of any kind so
I wanted to juxtapose the concepts of
the cloud which i think is an overused
term the cloud is what hipsters call
hosting and then the browser which is an
underutilized tool now there was a
fellow who said that they thought that
there was a world market for maybe five
computers this is supposed to be one of
those quotes that is
on the internet that you just believe I
think it was Abraham Lincoln that said
that you can't trust quotes on the
internet and Thomas J Watson I guess was
the head of IBM and had said that
there's this world market for maybe five
computers they were thinking like
refrigerator-sized computers that like
were on a continent so there'd be like
the Australian computer and then you
would just send batch jobs off to it
right and there'd be one in Europe and
then once we'd sold out of all the
computers that were available that we
would be done and that would be the end
of it and then maybe if you know with
the brexit maybe there's six computers
because they're going to want their own
but that's fine so I can't prove that
Thomas J Watson said this but I do have
this really old book so we'll just say
that that's the guy because if I'm going
to be making up quotes we need headshots
to prove it now this really happened
though those five computers actually
happened except it's Microsoft and it's
Google and it's the book store we call
it the book store because like when the
bosses at work like how are we losing to
a book store this is a this is a picture
of the azure cloud we are a little
behind but we do get color now so that's
that's pretty good and we're upgrading
constantly so we're getting new brand
spankin new refurbed as your equipment
and this guy is whoops
there we go that's maybe better he's
pretty excited about that
so the gentleman in Intel wanted to
understand the cloud and I tried to
explain to him well you know it's more
than just having a computer that's not
in this room because where that is the
cloud right it's just an IP address that
isn't in your in your subnet I said well
let's back up let's talk about hardware
let's talk about what are the
characteristics of an operating system
what do you need to have in order to
call something an operating system you
need to have memory management and
graphics and security and all those
things and then a hardware abstraction
layer that sits in this operating system
and then that is you know an
architecture diagram but then when you
give it portability that's where the
magic happens
and I remember the very first time that
I saw a virtual machine and be able to
run stuff in a window and pick a virtual
machine up and take it somewhere even
having virtual machines in your pocket
is is a miracle like that was when it
all started
and in the cloud the or the naive cloud
we call that lift and shift right that's
when you take a virtual machine that's
sitting under someone's desk and you
pick it up and you move it into the
cloud but it's when I say naive I mean
that a lot of people say that that's
their cloud strategy they just went from
managing machines under their desk that
ran virtual machines to manage managing
machines in the cloud so what value did
they get other than that they are
renting as opposed to owning the the car
but there are some benefits of course
you can do cool things like running
Linux in Azure which continually freaks
me out it turns out that 25% of the
workload in Azure is Linux did you know
that and the bosses are like why are you
allowing that to happen how is that ok
and Guthrie Scott Guthrie who runs Asher
says well what do you think they're
running on they're running on Windows so
we don't really care I think that
Microsoft should change their marketing
slogan to Microsoft wants your for loop
because that's what that's what there is
the dirty little secret about what is
Microsoft selling now right before they
sold Windows and then now they sell
office but they sell it on iPhones and
Android phones really Microsoft
care what you run as long as your
for-loop whatever language it's written
in is running up in Azure so they have
things like VM Depot where you can have
thousands and thousands of Linux based
VMs and I can go up here and say I want
a Jenkins VM and I want to go and say as
your VM create and then spin up a
virtual machine I asked the guy at Intel
how do you get VMs now he has to fill
out a form and fax it like that's how
that's the Jason I maybe he just writes
Jason on a fax and then it's just really
high latency sends that fax and maybe he
gets back like a single fax that says
200 okay I don't know how it works you
know maybe he gets a call back where
it's like success but not ready I don't
know but a real cloud isn't about
picking up a virtual machine and
sticking it off elsewhere it's about the
programmability of it right it doesn't
matter if it's Asher or if it's Amazon
or if it's Google it's the difference
between a a host which is just renting
space for your virtual machines and the
ability to programmatically create them
so going and saying something like as
your VM create goes and sends a web
service call up to this endpoint and all
I think about is the general region that
my my VM lives in and of course I've got
ASCII art which makes Microsoft less
evil but it's a complete programmatic
back-end more significantly it's the
same back-end that the portal uses so
when Microsoft goes and makes virtual
machines or makes webs websites they're
using the same API that we can call and
that's really meaningful so it's the
automation of the cloud that's
interesting now he wanted to know though
should I just make VMs or should I make
something else I'm not a fan of virtual
machines I think that virtually seasoned
virtual machines are cool I was excited
when they happen but you still have to
maintain them right they're free like a
puppy you know it's like oh hey cool
puppy new virtual machine that's great
oh wait I have to run Windows Update on
the thing I don't want to run Windows
Update on my puppy that's not good
I got to call apt-get update and apt-get
upgrade and I can't remember which one
I'm supposed to run so I just run them
over and over
and over again until the Linux machine
shuts up when when the heartbleed virus
virus malware evil bug happened when
hardly broke and then the openness they
open to sell stuff I had to wake up at
2:00 in the morning and SSH or shush
into these machines don't you all say
that shush in so I shushed into these
machines and I had to patch them but
they were running like newsletter
systems and expense reporting systems
why am i dealing with the maintenance of
that I feel that that should have
happened on its own virtual machines are
ok but you managed them but I think
about things in terms of apps if I'm
running an expense reporting system I'm
going to put it up somewhere and I want
it to run I don't have to wake up at
2:00 in the morning to patch it for SSL
bugs that's silly it does give you power
though you can do anything you want on a
virtual machine and run anything you
want it's like as if a you know a
virtual machine is your home right it's
your home or it's your first car you can
treat it however you want and you can
destroy it if you want to but again I
don't want to have to think about it
especially with things like Windows
Update you know how you have to if you
ever had that situation with Windows
Update when you're typing and you're
doing your thing and then time slows
down and then you see that the Windows
Update dialog is going to pop up and you
just happen to be pressing enter at the
same time and the dialogues coming up
and your hands going down and gravity
has a hold of your hand and the restart
Now button is default and I don't know
why that was a good idea you're like
just oh I'm writing some great code it's
like
and the dialogue is coming up and
there's there's only one way to stop
that right did you know that there's
only one way to stop a Windows machine
is a dirty notepad if you have notepad
see I can't even this is this machine is
going to reboot not bad dirty notepad
that that will stop Windows from right
because it's like the most powerful
server cloud-based operating system on
the planet and it's like the system is
rebooting that Oh notepad is dirty
sorry not responding not responding and
then everything just stops so on my
server machines I renamed notepad to N
so I just go windows R and I make it
dirty and I just leave it there someone
suggested that you just leave a dirty
notepad always on a Windows machine and
it'll run forever but I haven't I have
not tested that theory that's a pretty
good idea though that machine's been up
for two years that's amazing how'd you
do it dirty notepad so I don't want to
think about that I want the cloud to
manage that I want to uplevel things a
little bit more so as I said you've got
virtual machines which you like your
first car
you've got cloud apps that have Azure
managing the updates you can still do
anything they're kind of like a rental
car but I'm more of a booze wah type I
like the the limousine I can do a little
bit less up there but it's handled
completely and it makes me very very
happy one of the things that's
concerning about that though as an old
person and I was talking to another
older person was that it kind of
invalidates a lot of my experience I've
got a multi-page resume you know how
you're supposed to make your CV only be
a page I think that's like a rule
mine's like three or four pages long but
I realized that pages two and three are
just how to scale a web farm right you
know remember configuring round-robin
load balancing and setting at the local
director and the Cisco and all that kind
of stuff remember back in the day when
setting up a web farm took like a
weekend and they would fly a consultant
in but now you just you just do a slider
bar is to think about as an old person
what that feels like that
two pages of my resume are gone and
they've been replaced by a slider bar
and I have to go to work with 22 year
olds that are like oh this webform is
taking like a minute sucks
Oh Pokemon I go and call as your site
scale and that line updating a server
farm basically says you wasted the 90s
it just it hurts it hits me in my soul
but the thing that was great about this
is that I don't need to know that
anymore right in the in this older
gentleman at Intel he's joining the web
now he doesn't need to think about
either
it's a solved problem so there's some
really interesting things that were big
deals when I was building these things
in the 90s and early 2000s like doing
something that we take for granted like
round robin load balancing on port 80
that was a big freaking deal that took
planning and vendors and now it is a
single line and I can I don't even have
to go to lunch I used to go to lunch or
work from home and tell my boss it was
going to take a long time so now I just
call a command like this make a server
farm and I'll tell my boss that it took
you know six to eight hours even though
it takes minutes so that slider bar has
destroyed my life and it makes me sad
but that's fine
the thing is though if you don't
understand what's happening underneath
then for you it's like what just
happened and then all I have to say to
the young people is magic
so you want to understand what's
happening underneath you don't want to
be forced into doing things a certain
way though what's nice about the cloud
whether it be Amazon or azor is that it
doesn't care about language choice the
next question that the gentleman asked
me was what language should I use to
write for the for the cloud write for
the web and I said you need to learn
JavaScript and a systems language some
back-end language that may also be
JavaScript but you need to know
JavaScript on the front end we'll talk
about in a little bit but you should
pick whatever makes you happy
dotnet node PHP well not PHP basically
anything but PHP you should you should
you should learn because it'll work
it'll work great in the cloud when I
told him that he became lightheaded and
thought that was great but you want to
use a cloud where it's all open source
and it's fun
again I'm I work on Azure so I care
about it but all of the SDKs are open
source so for teaching someone the web
if you're teaching them something where
they can look at the code and that code
is is somewhat self documenting is a
good thing we've got piles and piles of
of open source in Visual Studio and
inside of of azor right now now when I
talk to him about up levelling you want
to understand what's happening
underneath but you also want to think
about what problems that you can solve
because you've raised the abstraction
layer if I'm not thinking about
individual virtual machines now how does
that change how I think about my systems
I was in Norway talking or Denmark or
somewhere Scandinavian I'm sorry there
were cobblestones and meat pies and
adrien Cockcroft was there he's the you
at the time it was the chief architect
of Netflix so I need you to understand
that this was a big deal ok this was
like an actual famous person and he
looked kind of like John Malkovich and
he was English which gives him you know
plus two charisma just for showing up
right he's got like a PhD in unsolvable
numbers and he works at Netflix so he
comes out and he starts talking about
some of the decisions that they needed
to make and Netflix
what they were doing was they were
switching from spinning rust right
spinning rust hard drives by the way if
you--if I can hear your hard drive you
can't work for me
I can't trust someone whose hard drive I
can hear really seriously if it's 2016
if you still have a hard drive that you
can hear you need to just get on board
and buy it with your own money when I
was working in banking they wouldn't let
us have SSDs I don't know why so I just
bought one and put it in myself it was
like 600 bucks which is a lot of money
at the time but it was too tall even if
it worked for a single year that's two
dollars a day and if you have an SSD I
think people who have SSDs know this you
just wake up happier you're taller your
hair lays better I mean just every the
Sun is bluer the sky is bluer the the
world is better when you're on an SSD so
they were moving the Netflix cloud from
spinning rust to SSDs and he was
explaining all of this because he's the
chief architect and he was thinking
about the AI ops write the input
operations or put output operations per
second eye ops is the term that they use
in the cloud that's just a number kind
of like an index of abstainer 'el speed
of your i/o and it was something like it
was $1.00 for 300 AI ops or it was like
six dollars for like three thousand so
it was like three times more money for
ten times more perf I did all the math
and it turns out that's a good deal so
he explains that they're going to switch
over there at Amazon and it was cool and
he gives this presentation and it was
amazing
and he was British and I loved him and
and then he said his thing and then one
of these 19 year old Danish Norwegian
Scandinavian kids comes up and he goes
well I can't do that actual accent so
I'll do this instead actually sir
you know SSDs are extremely unreliable
and the mean time before failure of an
SSD is a year and I find that in --see
and he basically said you're an idiot
SSDs are totally unreliable and they're
going to fail on you and it's going to
destroy Netflix and you suck now think
about what it must feel like to be that
kid who's talking to the I mean you
should be deferential just because
Netflix not just because he's English
but because he's from
but he stood there and he took this this
question which basically like you made a
bad decision you're an idiot
and he says what do you think about that
how are you going to deal with what
happens when all those SSDs fail and
you've destroyed your company and he
says that's not my problem I'm renting
them I'm renting them think about that
what happens if those SSDs fail is that
his problem
no it's Amazon's problem they have an
SLA they have a service level agreement
he's thinking about the numbers which is
this much money that much perf it was a
no-brainer they had the money they got
the perf yes SSDs can have problems yes
when they fail they fail spectacularly
but if he has a cloud architecture that
can deal with that and deal with with
change then it's going to be fine
you may be familiar with Amazon's
attitude Netflix is chaos monkey chaos
monkey right it just it's a software
program that runs around an unplugged
stuff at Netflix does just see what
breaks it's a really great idea like if
you break the database so it can't be
written to you can still browse the
catalog right think about that if you
have a product catalog with a shopping
cart if you suddenly made the database
read-only with the app deal with that
would it say oh sorry we having some
issues with a shopping cart but feel
free to browse the product site or would
you just die and that would be the end
of it so having a resilient system like
that is really important so when he said
this to this kid that's not my problem
I'm renting them the kid didn't even
know that he'd been cut in half it was
like a samurai movie where the guy kind
of goes like Shoop you know with like
the superhero landing and then the head
gets chopped like this and it rolls down
and falls and the brain is exposed and
it's just like this but you don't know
if the body should fall and someone
should push it over all right I don't
have a gif of that but I do have this
we'll do that again just to make sure
you understood what actually happened
there it was a maze never mess with an
Englishman it works from Netflix they've
got a global dashboard they really
understand how these things work when
you're doing something in the cloud I
suspect when they move to to Europe they
just pushed a button and like went to
lunch and they ran some shell script and
then like Netflix just went over to
Europe they really think about these
dashboards and that's another thing I
was telling this gentleman at Intel
about is how important it is to uplevel
your perspective you're thinking about
the applications larger health and not
the individual processes on an
individual box so you want to have a
really nice configurable dashboard
that's going to do what you want now
sometimes people take it too far but you
can't argue that that's okay I've seen
people be like I got a dashboard that's
my dashboard now I know everything
that's going on I got I got that one too
it's even better it's an upgrade H top
you can't argue that H top is is a
dashboard you can't you like they say
that they argue that that is the case
but it's not the case you can't argue
that Mario is the superior Mario
Brothers it has always been Luigi I
don't care what you say about it you
just you know Luigi always it's always
Luigi so when people are against the
cloud they're missing out on this new
this the benefits that this new layer of
abstraction has there is a really
interesting problem that the New York
Times had recently about a year and a
half ago where they had a bunch of
Tiff's that represented all of the
scanned issues of the New York Times
going back like hundreds of years
okay 160 years whenever it started in
the 1800s and the problem was for these
interns was to take these Tiff's
terabytes of them and turn them into
ocr'd
text-based searchable PDFs that kept the
fidelity so it was one of those problems
where you're probably solving it in your
mind right you know it's like okay
figure out the optimal size resize OCR
or make sure the text is embedded in the
metadata of the PDF for each
issue do the thing right it's a naive
parallel operation for each issue in
issues do it except it was huge this is
a massive problem with terabytes of
stuff and they needed to do it they
needed to do it in a weekend so they
were told to do this in the past what
would we do we would we would buy
machines we would run around the office
and get anyone who would give us a
machine to do that kind of work or you
go to the cloud and then you start
getting all these machines together and
then you have to think about well what
am I going to do with these machines do
I chop the problem up a thousand at a
time
suddenly the issue doesn't become an
issue of the business problem which is
make PDFs of the New York Times right it
becomes a computer science problem where
it's like well I'm going to parallelize
it but am i parallelizing it across
disks across processors across processes
and I multi-threaded am I not and what
happens is when you find yourself in
situations like this is that your boss
comes by and says well how's the problem
going and he sees you shaving a yak if
you know about yak shaving and you're
shaving this yak and you're like oh hang
on I'm working on it I'll be done as
soon as I'm finished shaving this yak
yak shaving is all the stuff that you do
while you're setting up to do the thing
you were originally asked to do right
there's a really great gift that
describes yak shaving that I'm going to
spontaneously get and not go into the
store it was bryan cranston yak shave
could be really concerning what i get
here by the way so let's just cross our
fingers and hope that it's appropriate
oh good i blogged about this once this
is a yak shaving hey i'm coming in a
light switch doesn't work i don't have
to fix the light i'm going to go ahead
and fix that light Oh light bulb is up
with oh this this shelf is broken I want
to fix the shelf before I get that oh
wait a second this is a squeaky squeaky
drawer man fix that squeaky drawer oh
I'm out of oil all right well I'll go
and I'll go to the store and get the oil
the car doesn't start oh well shoot hey
fix that lightbulb in the kitchen what
does it look like I'm doing that is the
modern cloud that is development in
today's cloud right it's got to shave
that yak so one of the things that you
would be able to do in a cloud scenario
with the right layer of abstraction if
you wanted to solve that problem like
the folks at The New Yorker or the New
York Times rather had is to make it some
kind of a function like this is just a
very naive function do it reads in some
content out of a reader writes in Iran
this in the cloud and then adds the
content back but you notice it doesn't
say anything about the cloud here it
just is a do it function where do it
could mean you know OCR that stuff but
if you could wrap that up with some
attributes or some metadata that says go
and get input from things that match
this glob from this this storage
location and then put the output over
here and then just have a slider bar
there's that slider bar again that says
well how much money do you have that's
really what you want to be able to do
all right that's what things like as
your functions and Amazon lambda does
where you say here's the business
problem you figure out the parallelism
of it dotnet does this with the task
parallel library right where it's like I
just want to think about this I don't to
think what the computer science beside
behind parallelism so being able to do
stuff like that changes how you do these
things
in fact the folks at the New York Times
ended up doing that for $300 in a
weekend at Amazon turns out it would
have been a hundred and fifty dollars
but they made a mistake on the first run
and they had to do it twice but think
about that I mean it would have cost
three hundred dollars just to buy an SSD
but they rented a bunch of machines for
the weekend and did that unfortunately
though things like lambda and things
like as your functions didn't exist at
the time so they wasted a bunch of time
solving the parallelism problem which
was a bunch of yak shaving that had
nothing to do with the issue they didn't
really use the class
they rented a bunch of VMs and then did
a bunch of busy work and then push the
button that did the OCR so I wanted to
juxtapose with the gentleman at Intel as
I was explaining to him was that the
idea that there are many more powerful
levels of abstraction on top of virtual
machines now up to the point where a
single function can be virtualized and
parallelized across multiple machines
then I wanted to turn attention over to
the browser so remember this these are
the characteristics of an operating
system and as memory management has API
as it has storage that is a operating
system there was a time when you would
sit in front of a machine that looked
like this but you were really talking to
one of those refrigerators that lived in
in Europe or lived in South America and
there were five of them and you would go
and you would load up a program oops
you would load up a program and you
would look at the user interface that
was on that screen but where was it
really running it was on the fridge you
were remoting it and this was called a
dumb terminal but we're doing that again
we're sending HTML over to super-powered
quad processor 3d accelerated machines
and pockets supercomputers and they're
waiting for more strings to come back
from the refrigerators that happen to be
in the cloud we we disparage these by
calling them dumb terminals and here we
are doing that again now Tim berners-lee
comes along and makes this this is the
first page of the world wide web this is
in fact the original page and you can go
to the original location and it's still
there there is actually a sign on it
originally in the lab that said don't
turn this off it's a server you imagine
if there was like the internet under
your boss's desk and there was a sign
that said don't turn off the internet
apparently he was a really really cool
guy and if anyone feels that they have
or anyone that their work has been
overstating their job title I want to
encourage you to think about Tim
berners-lee in his job title he could
have said the
but he didn't and that's really classy
so we don't get until he becomes a
senior then apparently I need to stop
putting Microsoft certifications at the
end of my time my name so when he put
this together he was thinking about
books he was think about hyper media and
this kind of infinite series of books he
never thought it would get as big as it
did and he didn't think about it as an
application platform it was a
information sharing platform and we
continue to try to add to it and change
it and push the web forward and what we
do is we invent stuff that the web can't
do until the web can do it and then we
get mad about the web doing what we
originally asked it to do you know he
didn't expect that we would need PDFs
but the web wasn't an attractive enough
document format so we invented PDFs not
we evil Adobe did but we we took their
evil and then they became the fifth most
popular religion on the planet and no
one no one expected that was going to
happen and it's the PDF extremists that
we need to work is when you use Acrobat
the terrorists win you can take that as
long as you as far as you want to take
that but I love that so the internet is
happening and then then this happens in
the middle of the internet developing in
the World Wide Web happening and how do
we know that this happened because we
were browsing the web and peace and that
and then Java loaded and then these guys
were like we can do it too and then
these guys again with the Adobe they're
like we've got YouTube we are still
useful but what were we building what
were we building we were doing that we
were trying to make a plug in virtual
machine a little square of computer
inside the square of the web inside the
square of our computer these little
islands of interactivity and then trying
to solve problems with them now I got
this Toyota Prius it's like the hybrid
d/f Priuses over here yeah where I'm
from Portland Oregon we're given one on
birth because we're very eco very eco
friendly and when I go to the the shop
the garage I always want to see their
systems I think most of us are nerdy
computer type people and you know how
when you're talking to someone behind a
kiosk whether it be at the airline
check-in counter you know you're like oh
I would kind of system while you're
running then the next thing you know
you're standing next to them is they
check you in on the airplane you're like
it's really so f7 upgrades me is that
how that works so so the guy at the
Toyota place knows that I'm always
interested in what's going on right and
they had a really interesting vt100
terminal-based system that was all
keyboard based and then one day I show
up and they've got these Dell kind of
like new them the the tiny Dell
workstation deals that go in the back of
the monitor and I said go new system
let's check it out I want to hear all
about it and he's like oh it's so good
let me show you what's going on so then
he boots up Windows XP and I was like uh
okay but I let him continue and he opens
up Firefox and then he goes to an
intranet site and then loads a jar file
and then Java is like are you sure you
want to run Java and he's like yes and
it's like you know enter your national
identification number and indicate that
you're really sure that this is a
phenomenally bad idea and then he's like
yeah this is a phenomenally bad idea if
to spell phenomenally bad right or Java
won't run and then Java pops up and he's
loading a terminal emulator in a jar
file that then connects to the same
as400 as before looks me in the face
with a straight face and says this is
way better than it used to be like you
know you've you've seen these before
you've worked on these systems they're a
nightmare this is not the internet that
we asked for
we didn't want these weird things where
we've got the body of a document and
then a weird little virtual machine
running with like physics demos it
doesn't work and I don't mean to
disparage Java but I mean - absolutely
disparage Java by July disparaging job
I'm disparaging the the applet scenario
because I bought into the applets I
worked at Nike in 1997 on hot Java
machines and I was right once debug
everywhere it's fine on the server but
it was a nightmare on the client now all
the while job is trying to take over the
world and then this happens javascript
starts up and remember the Java people
don't like that so don't don't do that
and if anyone ever says is what is
johnny's java relate to javascript just
fire them on the spot they can't they
can't they can't be allowed to live just
kidding
javascript when that happened I started
to get a sense that maybe this could be
something this could be this could be
powerful now it is complicated and it is
frustrating this is a flow chart about
what it's like to work in JavaScript
do you remember the first time that you
did something useful in JavaScript it
may not come yet may not have happened
yet but it the first time something
useful having a JavaScript for me I
think we've all had this moment is that
you're filling out a form and you get
your phone number wrong and you hit tab
and then the field goes to a different
color and you went
it's like squirrel then you go back and
you type it again because you can't
believe what just happened and you hit
tab and you go I don't think it posted
back to the server I think it did the
validation on the form on the
client-side view source see a bunch of
stuff you can't possibly understand and
you go it did and I grabbed my computer
and I ripped it out I started running
like this because I'm a nerd and I can't
run and I show my wife I'm like hit
validated when the client she's like I
don't care so then I run to my boss and
she doesn't care nobody cares but it
meant that JavaScript was more than just
saying alert pwned
you know as your first name right or you
know little Bobby tables as your last
name it means that JavaScript can really
do useful stuff and then people started
doing things like this there's a
complete Commodore 64 emulator written
entirely in JavaScript like that's a
thing someone did that and they did that
because it's the Internet and they could
do that and that's insane then I saw
this
this is a complete implementation by the
way is is it I didn't know that the you
all as a country had just the two
megabits a second do you share that pipe
there's so many interesting UI decisions
that were made at Microsoft products
that you don't realize how badly they
suck until you come to Oz or New Zealand
and you go wow if we just assume 40
megabits a second then we you know
that's that will design the UI this way
but if you only have Australia bandwidth
you might want to pop a dialog box and
say go to lunch so when you see
something amazing in a browser like an
entire Linux emulator written in
JavaScript what you do is you select the
text and you have to select over the
border to make sure that it's not flash
because oftentimes people will show you
cool stuff in the browser and you'll
right click on it and it says about
Flash and you go R'lyeh
but this is real this is real I can
actually go in here and I can say run
TCC and compile that and one time I was
doing this particular demo at an open
source conference and I was compiling a
C application in a JavaScript Linux VM
in a browser on Windows and one of the
neckbeards yelled out why aren't you
using GCC I'm sorry sir you're
questioning my choice of C compiler in
the JavaScript implementation of the
virtual machine that's running in the
browser that's running on Windows and
really I'm going to run whatever the I
want to run I was a little bit
disappointed so what I did was I then
launched an iPhone emulator and ran a
via VIN Linux virtual machine in it just
to make the point about how cool this is
because it's like Inception right and if
you saw inception you know that
Inception is all about if you run a
virtual machine inside another virtual
machine time slows down
that's the whole point that's the
information that I got from that film
and that DiCaprio continually gets
robbed he was in that right so now you
have people who say well I I browse the
web without JavaScript I also do
CrossFit and I'm a vegan I've actually
met people who have told me that they do
CrossFit and they're a vegan and they
run with JavaScript disabled before I
got their name which is convenient
because at that point I don't want to
know their name can't run with that does
it right but does it run without
JavaScript disabled no idiot
brick does it running links well yeah
actually it's a responsive design you
can do amazing stuff in JavaScript that
people aren't doing it this is an
interesting one this is this was a 2012
iPad game of the year they reimplemented
the entire thing in JavaScript and now
at this point in the talk sometimes
people assume that I'm going to go and
show them you know doom or the Unreal
Engine running in the browser and
they're going to say oh okay Scott I get
it you're going to talk about how you
can take C or C++ and you can literally
compile it through clang into
lightweight virtual machine bytecode run
that to something like as MJS runs on
top of OpenGL here's the part of the
demo where you show quake in the browser
so cliche no I'm not going to do it
because it's cliche I'll try to find
something else that's better what I will
do is I will overlay the features of
JavaScript on top of the characteristics
required for an operating system so
you've got garbage collection you've got
graphic subsystems you've got both 2d
and 3d you've got web workers it seems
like JavaScript could from a textbook
perspective be perceived as an OS we're
shipping an extra OS with our browsers
and Jeff Atwood very wise Jeff Atwood
that's a selfie said that any
application that can be written in
JavaScript will be written eventually in
JavaScript everything will eventually be
written again in JavaScript
uh that is true but in fact also is true
is that anything that can be written in
Microsoft Excel will eventually be
written in Excel how do you open it with
really Excel do I not have really Excel
that's disturbing oh well thanks for
telling me that Excel I needed to know
that about 20 minutes ago
show recovered files that always ends up
well for me something horrible happened
a long time ago and here's a file I
saved because of it this is such an
amazing application here this is a
complete implementation of pac-man done
in Excel where each individual cell is a
pixel and it is so powerful that it
can't be stopped
that's almost like a virtual machine all
right you may have seen a have heard
about my my Halloween costume last year
I went as Microsoft Outlook I got a
shower curtain and kind of an opaque
curtain that I hung in front of me so
you can kind of see me but there was
like a sheen over me that said not
responding and then I would just walk
around and refuse to speak to anyone why
is he not talking to anyone now he's
trying to put a bite on the network
because that's what Excel that's what
outlook seems to do doesn't it
so we're shipping another operating
system aren't we we've got one that's
running on these pocket supercomputers
that we have that is the JavaScript VM
and we can do amazing powerful things
with it there's so much that has
happened we see images like this that
show what we carried apparently in our
pockets in 1993 and now what we carry
here but we don't talk about the fact
that that pocket supercomputer has 3d
accelerated graphics multiple processors
and a very competent JavaScript virtual
machine of course we also don't talk
about all the creativity that has
occurred since the iPhone was released
yeah I'm looking forward to a pink one
now this guy says that html5 and
JavaScript were too early and they bet
on it too early and they went back to
native but I don't think that's true
because people have proven time and time
again that if you really understand
JavaScript and you really understand how
the system works you can create some
really really amazing stuff I would even
go so far as to say that many bosses are
out there saying well can we do that in
JavaScript can we do that in html5 you
know is it is it too soon one of our
great philosophers said this the
Avalanche has already begun it's too
late for the pebbles to vote the
Avalanche is html5 and JavaScript it's
happening anytime your boss says well is
that possible with JavaScript yes is
probably the answer is it possible in
the browser absolutely we have complete
JavaScript implementations of PDF
renders in the browser if you go to
office
komm it's actually enough for
non-technical parent to have word in
Excel without ever installing word in
Excel I really think that the
outlook.com clients better than outlook
and it's written in JavaScript that is
continual proof as it gets better and
better
who said that you remember who said this
no it was cost from Babylon 5 what a
bunch of nerds how do you not know that
it's on a classic sci-fi now when we say
html5 what do we really mean html5 has
become that that catch-all thing just
like cloud means too much html5 means
too much right it's the collection of
specifications and technologies
including ECMO Script css3 html5 and
it's hard sometimes to tell what is
html5 but I've got a very simple test
for you if it runs outside internet
explorer then it's interesting html5 if
it doesn't run and Internet Explorer its
html5 that's your basic test just try it
out you may actually have an html5
website right now you don't know about
you should just run it in IE and say
sorry boss let's say html5 being a web
designer is tough now there was a time
when HTML tables was the most advanced
thing ever
remember this anyway all my old people
here old heads yes you could get a job
just knowing HTML tables you would go
into work and they'd say do you know
HTML tables and you'd say yes yes I do
boom junior engineer I went into a job
they said do you know how to do rowspan
and in fact I did and I was running the
company and I also know that internet
that Netscape Navigator can only handle
32 nested tables and the only way that
you know that is when you've written
that 33rd table and stared Satan himself
in the face that's true
but hTML is simpler than ever now I've
seen pages that are just a div write
HTML just provides that structure CSS
gives that color in the style and CSS is
another language that the gentleman at
Intel needs to learn but it's very
simple and expressive and CSS always
gives you
what you want the very first time
super-powerful
so there's someone selling this mug and
the best part about the fact that this
mug is sold is that there's another
version of this mug where they tried to
fix it I don't know what's better now
javaScript is everything else and when I
tried to explain to JavaScript to this
gentleman at Intel even though it's
taking over the world I basically said
in Ruby everything is an object
enclosure everything's a list and in
JavaScript everything is a terrible
mistake here is a ja a gif of me
learning JavaScript it's great because
you don't need to learn the bad parts
good parts ED parts notice also there's
a rhino on this and a butterfly on that
one so I don't know who decided that the
covers of these things are really really
interesting the other thing that I
discovered I saw this tweet from Shay
saying that there's noun je s like you
pick a noun and there's a JavaScript
library for it so I took that challenge
from him and I discovered this very
concerning JavaScript library hey you
want fart noises when you scroll
now of course the problem with that was
that I went there and I was like what no
jQuery plug-in that sucks but you know
javascript is intuitive
it's a couple of things you have to
learn just a few things to make it
really clear that one's concerning this
is me debugging JavaScript now the
gentleman John Resig who invented jQuery
wrote this amazing book you should get
called secrets of a JavaScript ninja
that is a samurai so I said hey John
Resig why is there a samurai on the
cover of secrets of a JavaScript ninja
and he says that's because JavaScript is
loosely typed ninja Samurai
duck typing I apologize for that joke
sorry
now I said javascript is the assembly
language of the web once that's a great
quote I'm going to make that a quote
everyone else said that though because
it's true it's one of those things that
you hear people saying that when I said
that folks on reddit and on the internet
thought that was a stupid thing to say
how dare you say that how dare you
propose that javascript is an operating
system how dare you propose that it's
the assembly language of the web so I
went to the people who made JavaScript
and I asked them do you think that's a
dumb statement do you think that that's
a really a thing because I think you can
compile to this kind of an assembly
language so I went and I talked to
Brendan Eich who invented that is
actually Brendan Fraser who I'm really
surprised he hasn't done a lot of movies
lately that is Brendan Eich but Brendan
Fraser is a beautiful man so we'll keep
him up there
he said that javascript is the x86 of
the web a couple of years ago but can't
claim it's original that's great that he
said he can't claim it's original
because it's one of those things that
just is obvious it's happening now the
very first time I said this I really got
dragged all over the internet people
saying that I was stupid and then this
happened we got it web assembly is
happening right they are formalizing a
subset of JavaScript to go and compile
to so rather than come trying to compile
to you know idiomatic JavaScript web
assembly with Google and Microsoft
and Mozilla is going to be a joint
effort and it's really happening so that
means that you're going to be able to
compile your C and C++ really to an
assembly language which means that
JavaScript just became the metal let's
think about that now you can take
languages like CoffeeScript and compile
it to or transpile it to idiomatic
JavaScript CoffeeScript is what Ruby
people wishes that JavaScript look like
or typescript which is what c-sharp
people wish that JavaScript would look
like but those two bits of code both
compile to the identical idiomatic
JavaScript so javascript is clearly
super-powerful and all I ask is that
people don't let the layers hide too
much complexity because you get a
library like fart scroll and you don't
understand how it works and you start
thinking that you're really slick but
you're not and too often we find people
saying that they don't write JavaScript
anymore they write jQuery right you know
you ask someone to go and do a selector
and say go and select this node and they
open up they go open Resig parent parent
anyway whoa whoa whoa like the dollar
sign is not built-in like you don't just
get to use that who said that that no
one writes JavaScript any more they
write jQuery there's actually jQuery
jQuery said that this article is about
the actor for the JavaScript library see
jQuery jQuery does not like that I use
this joke but he's actually an actor but
the great thing is that once you know
about jQuery that you actually can never
use jQuery again right because you'll be
at your work and they'll be like hey we
should probably use jQuery for that I
mean like I don't know if he's available
but I'll call his agent let me let me
check his IMDB page to see what jQuery
is currently working on I think he's
just finished filming an episode of
Chicago Fire so I can't even say jQuery
without thinking about jQuery you think
that you're going to build something and
you have an image in your mind about all
the great stuff that's going to happen
when you use these JavaScript libraries
and then you go and you
oh that thing and it ends up not looking
right and you don't know who to blame
and then you're sad you're like I don't
know so I would really propose that
people start thinking about vanilla Jas
when you learn JavaScript like I told
this gentleman at Intel you got to learn
the metal we teach kids assembly because
it's fun to watch them in pain and then
we teach them C and we go out forget
about assembly you really needed to see
and they go oh why didn't you show me C
before well and then once they're done
suffering in C we teach them C sharp or
Java and we go out memory management no
one does that anymore and then we and
then in the future we're going to teach
them things like you know service fabric
in the actor model and all that kind of
stuff and they're going to completely
forget what's underneath the metal the
problem is that then you have people
going and writing their own stuff so you
have to find that balance do you do you
pick a library and count on it and then
have no idea what's happening underneath
or do you start at the metal and then if
you're dumb
write your own JavaScript framework do
you know that there are actually more
JavaScript frameworks than there are
apps that use JavaScript frameworks you
think would be like at least a one to
one but it's not so I would tell you
this expect more from your web and your
web tools we're at a place right now
where things work pretty well together
things at the web at this point in 2016
are starting to get really nice if you
exclude the crappy browsers and you just
aim for a functional web a reactive web
a web that does feature detection you
can get yourself in a pretty nice spot
and on the cloud side you have
effectively unlimited scale and your
choice of languages but what I would
encourage people to think about is on
the browser side remember that that
machine that runs that browser is
deceptively powerful you've got
accelerated graphics even on the
crappiest machines you have an
integrated virtual machine that you are
probably not using so if you have 10
virtual machines in your farm and you
have a thousand people hitting it don't
forget that those thousand people have
quad processors so you really have a
thousand plus 10 virtual machines
why are you when you when you sort a
list
posting the data back and asking the
server to sort that why aren't you using
things like d3.js to do your graphics
generation start using those powerful
virtual machines and the JavaScript that
is available on them your cloud does not
need to work so hard thanks so much for
letting me do this here and the NDC
Sydney let's give a big hand for the
folks who are working so hard to put on
a great show for you let's say goodbye
and go have some fun thank you